- Come in.
(door opening)
- That it?
Is that the welcoming committee?
- What more is to be said?
- [Charles] How about
"thank you" or "well done"?
- If we all had to thank one another
every time we did anything in this family,
we'd never get anywhere.
- I've just been on a very challenging
post-investiture tour of Wales.
It went better than anyone expected.
Thank you.
- You were sent to Wales to show respect
and heal divisions, not inflict
them on your own family.
- I did nothing of the sort.
- I've had the opportunity now
to read the translation
of what you actually said
and the inferences you made.
The similarity between Wales'
suffering and yours was clear.
- Was it?
- Unmistakable.
- Only to you.
- To all Wales, apparently.
If this union is to
endure, then we must learn
to respect each other's differences.
Nobody likes to be ignored, to not be seen
or heard or listened to.
- Well, am I wrong?
Isn't there a similarity
between my predicament
and the Welsh?
Am I listened to in this family?
Am I seen for who and what I am?
No.
Do I have a voice?
- Rather too much of
a voice for my liking.
Not having a voice is something
all of us have to live with.
We have all made sacrifices
and suppressed who we are.
Some portion of our natural
selves is always lost.
- That is a choice.
- It is not a choice.
It is a duty.
I was a similar age to you
when your great-grandmother,
Queen Mary, told me that to do nothing,
to say nothing, is the hardest job of all.
It requires every ounce
of energy that we have.
To be impartial is not
natural, it's not human.
People will always want
us to smile or agree
or frown or speak and
the minute that we do,
we will have declared a position,
a point of view, and
that is the one thing,
as a royal family, we
are not entitled to do,
which is why we have
to hide those feelings,
keep them to ourselves
because the less we do,
the less we say or speak or agree or--
- Think.
Or breathe or feel or exist.
- The better.
- [Charles] Well, doing
that is perhaps not
as easy for me as it is for you.
- Why?
- 'Cause I have
a beating heart.
(poignant music)
A character.
A mind and a will of my own.
I am not just a symbol.
I can lead not just by wearing a uniform
or by cutting a ribbon, but
by showing people who I am.
Mummy, I have a voice.
- Let me let you into a secret.
No one wants to hear it.
- Are you talking about the
country or my own family?
- No one.